تحيه من القلب حقيقه لكل اللي نورونا
وفعليا استمتعنا بكل مقابله معاهم وللم
وللامانه يعني المقابلات كان فيها كثير من
الضحك مين فيكم اللي حيكون حبيب انت ولا
حمدي
شنو شايفه يا ساره يعني اكيد انت يا خالد
صح اكيد انت اللي حبيبها تكون انت المؤلف
والمنتج
والماكي اكيد يعني طبعا حتزبط الامور انه
كل البنات تحبك انت اكيد يعني خلص مفهومه
تمام
يا خالد
لا هذه مسؤوله خليها ب 25 سؤال لما انت
تجي صح يعني حرفيا ما توقعت لدرجه انه في
في وقت ما شفت كاميرات وعرفت انه مقلب بس
ما توقعت انه رامز اوكي بس كان نفسي اضربه
بصراحه يعني
خلاص
كذا بعدين يقولوا السعوديات ما يضربوا ما
ياخذوا حقكم يعني شوفي هو جاهل اللي جاه
بس يعني كان ودي اكثر بالضبط
يعني نقطه ضعف بصراحه
حلوه
مش معقول ايدك يعني بتشيل على طول يعني
وبتحطه وبتخبي سرقتي كل المسلسل ايش الوضع
معك خافي على نفسك لاحسن
الحمد لله
[ضحك]
سلمي يا سوسو خلينا الله
سلمي يا سوزي طيب
بالتوفيق في علاقتك وقصه حبك مع سوزي ان
شاء الله يعني تكبروا سوا
ما احلى السنه الجايه وهي سنه واربع شهور
تكون ان شاء الله
شكرا لك يا ساره وتشرفت بالمقابله دي
ودائما المقابله بتكون يعني والله انت
اللي وشك حلو عليا مش انا العكس وربنا
يعني يا رب دائما بعملها عاده وتكون سوزي
كبرت بقى رمضان الجاي تيجي معنا
[ضحك]
تعالوا الان
يعني ايش
صار يعني خليني اقول انا اقول لك انا
فعليا فعليا من الناس اللي يحب شعري فابغى
اشوف اي طريقه المهم غير اني احلقه لانه
ما شاء الله لما يكون واقف كانه ياشر من
بعيد
المدام ظفرته قلت خلاص تمام
[ضحك]
وحش تمثيل ما قصدك وحش ثاني لانورطك على
الهوا يا هشام وما ترجع البيت
[ضحك]
ان ما عندناش قطن مصري انا عايز اعرف مين
بقى
يخش جوه الشاشه ويمسك القماش كده ويقول لا
والله ده مش كتان ده قطن ده ازاي يعني
احمد مظهر ده طوله 165 سم
يعني حضرتك اطول منه
هو الحقيقه يعني يا خالد لو انت عرفت طول
الحقيقي ما كنت هتقول الجمله هذه لانه
احمد ما ظاهر اطول مني بكثير الحقيقه يعني
الله يرحمه يعني
خلاص يعني
عيدي لي موضوع الجميله علشان الزملاء اللي
بيشككوا فيها
تمام
المسلسل بشتغل عليه تقريبا سبع ثمان شهور
ما بيتبقاش ليا فيه غير اسمي فمش عارفه
تمام
عشان انا بعمل ثلاث حاجات في المسلسل لا
حلو حلو خلاص مسلسلك برضو يلا حط اسمك فين
ما تبغى فيه ههه محمد كمان
امي بتفرح يعني امي اكتر حاجه بتفرحها هي
وابويا الاسم ده
10 مرات هكتبه لها اذا نحط طول المسلسل
كده على جنب طول الوقت المسلسل ما يارب
ابقى شربير بالشكل ده وانجح مع الناس يعني
زي ما كنت في الصفاره لطيف برده يعني على
القلب تبغى تكون طيب ههه
تقدر تعمل حاجات الراجل ما بيعملهاش يعني
الست بتحمل وتربي وتكبر وتشتغل في نفس
الوقت انما كان في فعلا فعلا
واذكى انت عايزه تضيعيني مع الرجاله
[موسيقى]
شكرا
واضح جدا يعني مساء النور بس مستاهل
الموضوع اتحفظ
حتى انا حتى انا لانه ما في احد تافه ما
لازم في احد ينقل عنه تافهه ابدا يعني
[موسيقى]
اكو ثلاث معاير
واحد واحد بس
وهو تافهه وكل شيء سوى تافه لو قلت اسمه
هتورطني طيب
[ضحك]
يعني مسكينه طبعا اكيد بتاخذ كثير تعليقات
خصوص كل الناس جالسه بتتابع المسلسل اهلا
فيك معانا يا هلا وكل عام وانت بالف خير
ولا الملكه صفصف تحب ننادي لك خلاص الملكه
لا لا الملك صدقت
خلاص يعني وصلت القمه الان هلا ايش اللي
عملته فينا هذا رمضان انت اسطوره اسطوره
اسطوره اسطوره في هذا رمضان الحمد لله يا
رب يعني هو نمبر وان مين هتخلفه يعني ملكه
فعلا
فعلا فعلا فعلا هتبقى
يعني
ضحكت مثل ما شفته كان ماخذ حيز محترم من
البرنامج